ukraine says zaparisia nuclear power
plant has now been reconnected to the
grid after these fires which it says
were caused by russian shelling took it
offline on thursday territory
president vladimir zelinsky said it had
risked a global radiation disaster but
nuclear experts say that is an
exaggeration
all this
is kind of a fear-mongering and both
sides needs electricity
so that's the reason that the plant is
still there and operating and
and they will need electricity hopefully
also in the future
nuclear engineer professor leon season
says there are multiple backup systems
during a disconnect and even in the
event of a meltdown this type of power
plant would only affect a 20 to 40
kilometer radius
on friday russia said it took out a
ukrainian howitzer gun that was
targeting the plant the same model that
was supplied by canada both sides have
accused the other of shelling it's
difficult to verify any of those
accusations but last month ukraine
released video of an airstrike against
russian forces just 300 meters from the
reactors the proposed visit from
independent inspectors would need all
violence to stop kiev
accepts it
moscow accepts it we need to go and we
are going to be there hopefully very
very soon one former nuclear inspector
told global news the terms of that visit
will decide what the world might learn
the hosts are going to take them to see
what it is they want them to see it'll
be interesting whether the ukrainian
people who are running the plant will be
allowed to interact with the iaea and
show them what they want to show yet no
matter how low the risk may be to the
wider world it's little comfort to those
who live close to europe's largest
nuclear power plant redmond shannon
global news london